so we're braving the elements ready to
repeat the experiment that we did quite
some time ago so you'll remember we had
a very small balloon of hydrogen match
on a stick to hydrogen BIGBANG coming
you ready yep here we go and the fact
that we've come outside might actually
give you an idea about what we're going
to do because we're going to make it a
little bit bigger so let's go fill a
balloon alright go well hydrogen I think
is very important because it's the
simplest atom it's the atom consists of
a positively charged proton which is
relatively large and a negatively
charged electron that goes round it
thank you thank you I think an electric
match will go well on that yeah look at
the tension on the balloon hold it I've
really gone for a run oh yeah the
tension what happens is that hydrogen is
reacting with oxygen and h2 plus o2
reacts to form h2o and an oxygen atom
and then that oxygen atoms goes on to
react with another hydrogen molecule to
make more water and the reaction
generates a lot of heat and that heat
heats up more gas to make it react
faster so you generate more and more
heat so the reaction that begins quite
slowly with the first few molecules runs
away and that's why you get the
explosion so here we have a rather large
balloon of hydrogen neil is just
preparing our electric match which we're
going to attach to the side of this
balloon and some of the biggest
explosions in the 20th century the
Chernobyl reactor the space shuttle that
blew up when it was taking off were in
fact explosion caused by hydrogen and
oxygen so we filled up a balloon of
hydrogen and I think if you look at the
hydrogen balloon you'll see that it's
slightly larger than those we've
attempted before
now we're going to try and detonate it
or burn the hydrogen in the air by
giving it a match and the match we're
going to use is again an electric match
which is connected to our detonator box
if you stick a pin in the balloon the
balloon will burst because the rubber
will break but the hydrogen will come
out and it won't react with the oxygen
because the hydrogen is cool it's at the
same temperature as the air but the
reaction of hydrogen and oxygen like
many reactions involves a so called
activation energy you have to put in a
certain amount of energy to get it going
but once you get it going you get more
heat coming out then you put in to start
it off so let's calm the circuit 5 4 3 2
that was more like lovely when Pete puts
the match to the balloon first of all
the match burns a hole in the balloon
and then the heat gets the hydrogen
oxygen near the outside of the balloon
and they start reacting and the heat
then spreads through the volume of the
hydrogen oxygen faster probably than the
balloon is bursting and as it spreads
through the temperature builds up and up
and up because you're generating so much
heat the reason that you hear a noise is
because the it causes a rising pressure
which sends a pressure wave out through
the air and it spits your ears or the
microphone on your camera I honestly
don't know why you see any color I
suspect that the color may actually be
caused by the burning balloon which
contains carbon and is really like the
flame on a candle because normally when
you have a hydrogen oxygen flame you
don't see any color at all alternatively
it may be some impurities in the gas but
I suspect that your what you're seeing
in the the fireball is just the burning
of the balloon the other thing which is
really quite exciting about hydrogen is
that in principle if you heat hydrogen
to really high temperatures you can get
two hydrogen atoms and to fuse together
or rather it will not work with hydrogen
but it will work with a heavier form of
hydrogen which is known as deuterium
where instead of a proton and electron
you have a proton and a neutron which is
a new neutral particle and an electron
and two molecules of deuterium confused
together to make one atom of here
which has two protons two neutrons and
two electrons and this produces a lot of
energy it is the basis of the so-called
hydrogen bombs which are like super
atomic bombs but which require an
enormous ly high temperature to get the
reaction to go so you can probably hear
it hissing and fizzing in the bottle
there you know there is a great hope
that in the end much of the world's
energy crisis can be solved by doing
this so-called nuclear fusion of
deuterium to make helium which would
produce energy extremely cleanly so here
we'll just tie it off my well Shanna's
can actually tie a knot on the end of a
balloon because you know we're a little
bit bizarre deuterium gas in all its
properties will be very similar to there
to the hydrogen of course it is not
denser because it has a neutron as well
as a proton but it's still much lighter
than air so a deuterium balloon will
still float up to the ceiling and make
pete look just as stupid as a hydrogen
one could I keep all of it are you
losing it you know but I was thinking
more about fusing it that sounds like a
really big explosion we could do at the
back no fusion reactors are way beyond
what people can do unless he's a lot
cleverer than I think I got a blues I
had a billion of hydrogen second time
you've done that now it's gonna go up
there eventually anyway